All right, so we got some practice
in how to use a bunch of different
user interface controls,
like how toggle buttons work in Android.
Let's keep building on that.
This section is all about menus.
We will practice how to
make an options menu.
You've probably accessed it previously
on your Android phone by tapping
the three dots on the top bar.
We will also learn how to make
a pop-up menu and a few other things.
So here's the drill.
We've found the best tutorials on the
Internet on how to use menus in Android.
What we want you to do is to read
the tutorials, follow the instructions
therein, and then create new apps to
learn more about how to use these menus.
Here we go.